what was your biggest failure and how
did I change you to really think hard
about that failure morning rings is my
favorite book is it yeah Nike what's the
closest thing to being a wizard in the
real world and that's like creating new
technologies it's not as much fun being
me as you'd think
I don't know you don't think so yeah I'm
not sure I want to be me need motivation
watch the top 10 we've believed nation
what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and make a difference using
it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being born in South
Africa to being severely bullied as a
child growing up to teaching himself how
to code at age 12 to becoming the
modern-day equivalent of Ironman
he's Elon Musk and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success volume 3 joy
let's get get off with rule number one
take risks one of the most difficult
choices I have ever faced in life was
was in 2008 and I think I had a good
maybe 30 million dollars left thirty or
forty one dollars left in 2008 I had two
choices I could put it all into one
company and then the other company would
definitely die or split it between the
two companies and but if I split it
between two companies then both might
die and you know when you put your blood
sweat and tears into creating something
a bully something it's like a child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it surprise I split the
money between two fortunately thank
goodness they both came through rule
number two create magic I've heard
people say listen he's out-of-the-box
thinker he's a businessman he's an
entrepreneur I feel that no man I
wouldn't say you would say I'm not only
a business plan you're not a businessman
no what are you I'm gonna show this
probably lots of analysts on Wall Street
who agree that I'm not a business
okay well what do you think you are I'm
engineer is it your dream to conquer the
world and make the world a better place
- what is your dream technologies like
magic you know to put I mean like
technologies the closest thing to magic
that we have in the real world and so I
think like engineering creative
engineering is essentially technology
development and I just made us when I
said I like Lord of the Rings is my
favorite book is it yeah
that'll be like what's the closest thing
to being a wizard in the real world and
that's like creating new technologies
rule number three don't rely on wishful
thinking young people nobody want to be
like Ella moss what's your advice of it
I think that probably they shouldn't
want to be hey you I think it sounds
better than it is okay yeah it's not as
much fun being me as you'd think I don't
know you don't think so yeah this
definitely it could be worse for sure
but it's I I I'm not sure I would I'm
not sure I want to be me
but if you know I think Madonna make
progress and things I think that but the
the best analytical framework for us and
in the future is physics
I'd recommend studying the the thinking
process around physics like not just not
the equations I mean equations certainly
they're helpful but the way of thinking
in physics is the that's the best
framework for understanding things that
are counterintuitive and and you know
always taking the position that you are
some degree wrong and your goal is to be
less wrong over time the one of the
biggest mistakes people generally make
and I'm guilty of a two is wishful
thinking you know like you want
something to be true even if it isn't
true and so you ignore the things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true this is a very
difficult trap to avoid and like I said
certainly one that I find myself in
having prawns with but if you just take
that approach of your oyster some degree
wrong and your goal is to be less wrong
and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends
particularly friends if somebody loves
you they want the best for you they
don't want to tell you the bad things so
you have to ask them okay you know it
said really I really do want to know and
then they'll tell you rule number four
survive failures what was your biggest
failure and how did I change you it's a
really think hard about that failure
there's your answer
well there's a ton of failures along the
way that's for sure
like I said as a support for SpaceX the
first three launches failed and we were
just barely able to scrape together
enough parts and money to do the fourth
launch that both launch had failed we
would have been dead so multiple
failures along the way I tried very hard
to get the right expertise in for for
SpaceX I tried hard to find a great
chief engineer for the rocket but it but
the good Chief Engineers wouldn't join
and the bad ones well there was no no
point hiring him
so I ended up a chief engineer at the
rocket so if I could have found somebody
better then we would have maybe had less
than three failures rule number five
solve big problems
his interest in our energy crisis
started last year
when South Australia a state already
heavily invested in wind and solar power
was plunged into darkness the result of
a massive storm that saw the state lose
power
Elon Musk tweeted headfirst into a
national political brawl when fellow
billionaire Australian IT whiz Mike
cannon Brooks question
Tesla's boast that he could help solve
South Australia's energy problems by
building the world's biggest battery why
did you do that
there was no idea of what would happen
afterwards just more if people make big
claims like that I'd like to check if
they're real you thought I was joking
because I had a checkbook with my team
it's like I hope I I didn't really say
something super crazy when you get a
return tweet from Elon saying yeah what
did you think so wait just checking his
kosha yeah he said he's gonna happen
Maggie let's make it happen right so
this is these are public tweets yeah and
but in a way that's that's part of our
locks in the guarantee right he's
putting his reputation online in a
public forum there that you know enough
noise was then created around enough
people saw that that it was like alright
that you know he'd better get that time
more than ever
Australians are struggling to pay for
their power a record number of families
are on hardship plans or deferred
payments and the rate of disconnections
in most states has risen sharply for
Elon Musk learning of this growing power
poverty is overwhelming cost of power is
making it almost a luxury item Wow
really everybody that I know is that
expensive
Australia has so many natural resources
I mean even if you go the fossil fuel
route yeah the electricity should be
very cheap there are Australians today
wondering if they can even turn on their
lights their Australian stay wondering
well should we go without some food sure
in in that's just not something you
would ever expect I did not expect that
hmm bukata it's necessarily true that we
will live under new renewables it's just
a question of when in fact it's it's
it's it's it's in the definition that if
it's not renewable that means it's going
to run out at some point and you will
have the choice of collapse of
civilization and into the dark ages we
go or find something that is renewable
so all of this is about saving ourselves
yeah
Avilan musk had his way the world would
be totally powered by renewables and
he'd be colonizing Mars he is a
big-picture man with big plans but it
might be his push for the modest lithium
battery will prove to be one of the more
significant steps in this electric
revolution you have been seen as a
catalyst somebody that is showing gosh
there is a there is another way yeah and
that's that's a great thing
people Australia should be should be
proud of the fact that history has the
world's biggest battery this is pretty
great and that it will serve as an
inspiration really to the whole world as
well just to say that this is possible
rule number six commit fully this is
widely regarded as one of the most
robotics driven auto assembly lines on
the planet
Elon one of the thing I heard about the
model 3 is that there's too many robots
that may agree you do you think so show
that maybe you need more people in here
working to do in some cases the robots
actually slowed the printer
where this crazy complex network of
conveyor belts and it was not working so
we got rid of that whole thing this is
cool yeah realizing it needed an
overhaul must personally took over the
model 3 production line at the beginning
of April raining for really extreme
levels of decision more than a of a
fifth of all he says he has resorted to
pulling all-nighters
at the plant I think so yeah really
intense I don't have time to go home and
shower change side sleep here
I wanted to see words I mean it's pretty
boring it's actually cold in here too
yeah I like it cool so you have a you
like it call I see when I catch her
there
so you're just laying here yeah I catch
yeah last time as you're actually step
literally on the floor cuz the couch is
too narrow yeah I was gonna say and Ilan
I have to say it's not even a
comfortable couch either no it's
terrible this is not a good catch musk
feels like all the overtime is paying
off and now he says the model three line
is back on track and we're able to
unlock some of the critical things well
holding us back from reaching 2,000 cars
a week but since then we've continued to
do 2,000 cars a week do you think that
this is sustainable
this page is sustainable yeah rule
number seven be a doer when you first
told me that you were thinking about
tunnels and I must tell you about that
years ago okay it's like a long time ago
like I thought you were joking yeah it
was always joking but it's not because
of some epiphany that I had one day
driving on the 405 that's how it gets
called translates and I was talking
about enols for years and years for
probably five years or four years at
least whenever I'd give a talk and
people would ask me about what
opportunities you do see in the world
I'd say tunnels can someone please built
tunnels so after four or five years of
begging people to build tunnels and
still no tunnels I was like okay I want
a bullet tunnel
like maybe I'm missing something here so
yes I was like basically talking feels
ears or tunnels right for several years
and then said well let's find out what
it takes to bullet tunnel and never so
started digging a tunnel I wanted to
start the tunnel from where I could see
it from my office at SpaceX it so stuff
I said well let's just cobble for part
of the parking lot across the road so I
can see if it's if anything's happening
or not and then we named our first
boring machine Godot because I kept
waiting for it and know it came finally
did and and regret it going and never
making good progress rule number eight
don't fear fear too much
what motivations that people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading about change and that's
not supposed to be an easy question oh
it's it's this well like I said I think
if you if you study engineering and you
figure out how to design new things then
it's relatively easy to start a company
you just need to get a few like-minded
people with you and and then focus on
creating a prototype for compelling
prototype as soon as possible and then
that you know there's there's a strong
venture capital industry in this country
that will give you funding to take
things to the next level and that that's
all there's to it and you might if you
know tried a few times might may or may
not succeed but I think sometimes people
fear fear starting a company too much
you know to say really what's the worst
that could go wrong you know coast off
to death you know you're not gonna die
of exposure
what's worse things go wrong rule number
nine push the limits how do you come
with this idea actually sometime they're
pushing the human limit you are always
pushing the human limit why
well I mean I think I think about what's
what technology solution is necessary in
order to achieve the particular goal and
then try to make as much progress in
that direction as possible I think the
being a multi-planet species being out
there among the stars is important for
the long-term survival of humanity and
that's one reason kind of like life
insurance for life collectively life as
we know it but then the part that I find
personally most motivating is that it
creates a sense of adventure and it
makes people excited about the future if
you consider two futures one where we
are forever confined to it until
eventually something terrible happens or
another future where we are out there on
many planets maybe even going beyond the
solar system I think that second version
is incredibly exciting and inspiring and
they need to be reasons to get up in the
morning you know life can't just be
about solving problems otherwise what's
the point
it's got to be things that people find
inspiring and make life worth living and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip have fun
[Music]
come with me when moombas hits the sky
you'll walk with me along the biome bye
okay all together now what about you
smile
my little buttercup where do you stay
awhile won't we stay beam's me the sky
and you and I walk by on fire
well this is really winning
[Applause]
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Elon Musk on how to be an
adventurer that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that I want to
know what did you learn from this video
from Elon what message struck you the
heart is that you're gonna apply somehow
immediately to your life or your
business write it down in the comments
below when you write it down you're much
more likely to actually take action so
let's see it thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
once you said do you want to die Mars
why I don't you clear I don't want to
die but it's like if I mean we're all
gonna die someday and if you're gonna
pick someplace to die then why not Mars
you know if we're born on earth why not
die on Mars seems like maybe if you be
quite exciting but I saw I think given
the choice of dying on earth or dying on
Mars I'd say yeah sure I'll done was but
it's not some kind of Mars death wish
and and if I do die on Mars I just don't
want it to be on impact got it the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon they believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]